it's Thursday March 24th and you're
watching gamespot news the only site
dedicated to tech coverage let's get
started first up if you have an iWatch
throw it out Pokemon go plus is coming
out pretty soon and they just released
new screenshots the pokemon company and
developer niantic have shared new
details on Pokemon go the upcoming
free-to-play game lets you catch pokemon
in the real world just like you've
always wanted as was discussed in the
leaked gameplay video Pokemon go
challenges players to go out the real
world and find and catch pokemon water
type creatures only appear in your
bodies of water such as lakes and oceans
the new screenshots show a little bit
more into how this game of work check
out that cute squirtle here are the
other highlights from Pokemon company's
announcement some Pokemon can be evolved
if the same species is caught on
multiple occasions Pokemon eggs which
can be found at poke a stops will hatch
after players walk a certain distance
players will be able to impress their
friends by unlocking achievement medals
that are earned by completing a variety
of challenges and during game play
pokemon go players will be encouraged to
join one of three teams engaging gym
battles with other teams the pokemon
company will also offer a portable
device called pokemon go plus a bracelet
like item that connects to your phone
via bluetooth and lets you know in
pokemon are nearby oh my god get your
money out get it ready top pine bullsh
this is happening a new report has been
confirmed that there's a more powerful
PlayStation in the works being referred
to as PlayStation 4 k reports that Sony
is working on a more powerful ps4 are
true according to digital foundry the
publication states that it has
independently verified a report
published on March 18th my bday which
said the new version of the console will
have an upgraded GPU now although more
than one source is referred to it as the
PlayStation 4 k it explains that even
though the hardware offers more graphics
processing power it's not enough to
deliver a robust 4k gaming experience
even though it might be capable of
high-definition media and some technical
aspects of 4k spec gaming such as high
dynamic range the hardware upgrade isn't
significant
enough to constitute a full step into 4k
gaming it goes on to speculate on three
viable upgrade path to the ps4 the first
involves making tweaks to existing
off-the-shelf hardware to decrease the
size of the consoles microprocessor
while increasing its power this would
leverage recent improvements AMD is made
to its CPU and GPU technology the second
involves scaling up the existing ps4
chip and attaching some features that
allow for select 4k features to be added
on the report notes that Sony must bear
in mind potentially splitting the PS
Wars audience and development resources
the subject of an upgrade to the ps4 was
previously discussed by a Sony executive
masakazu Ito who said the company might
consider a high-power ps4 and on the
other spectrum of the piece kale digital
foundry has conducted a technical
analysis of Dark Souls 3 on the Xbox one
and found that it ran at a native
resolution of 900 sheep while it doesn't
run in native 1080p it's up scaled from
900p digital foundry said the game still
looks impressive specifically calling
out its use of anti-aliasing digital
foundry also looked at dark souls 3 s
frame rate on xbox one and found that as
was the case with from software's
blood-borne the game's locked 30 FPS
with vsync leaves something to be
desired this means that while we do hit
a 30 FPS line on average we still get
the perception of stutter anyway with
several unique frames running in a row
followed by multiple duplicates it found
going on to note that the opening
section of the game dips down to 25 FPS
in a scene involving heavy fog effects
in some scenarios including large-scale
situations the framerate can reportedly
fall to 20 FPS fortunately we get 30 FPS
average for most of this law threat
section and it's only in these isolated
spots where the xbox one struggles an
analysis of the playstation 4 version of
Dark Souls 3 is coming in the days ahead
as well as presumably a breakdown of the
PC Edition will let you know those specs
when more details are revealed Dark
Souls 3 is now out in Japan but tough
but for the rest of us we don't get it
until April twelfth so that's all the
news we have for you today on this third
day I'll be back again tomorrow and it's
canine friday so it's going to be good
see you then